So you may be wondering how is that people who grow up in the same family can
grow up in different environments? Well, birth order is one way this can
happen. And by birth order we just simply mean whether you're first child or
second child or fourth child or whatever. Now birth order really can affect our
personalities. In general, the evidence suggests that first born children, for
example, tend to be more conservative. They tend to be more responsible. And
they tend to have a higher self esteem. And then latter born children, people
second, and third, and fourth, and so on tend to be more rebellious and
challenge the status quo. In fact, the psychologist Frank Sulloway wrote a book
called, Born to Rebel and it was all about birth order. And he studied the
history of science and politics and the reason he chose these two areas was
because they have revolutions pretty regularly. New ideas come on and he wanted
to see who accepted and who rejected these new revolutionary ideas and as it
turns out, the best predictor of who accepted and rejected these new ideas was
birth order. First born children tended to reject new ideas in science and
politics. And latter born children tended to accept them. So birth order really
does affect our personalities.